I spent a whole lifetime building this
and as long as I'm in charge nobody is
going to knock down that kind of that's
what they are colors they swish the
night off
hello elimination my name is Derek
Tarnow Mars one would believe it I will
need an entrepreneur's will of all of
the world's major problems so to help
you on your journey today we're going to
learn through the first prime minister
of Singapore Lee Kuan Yew my take on top
ten rule number two is my personal
favorite and it loves know which ones
because like them and as always guys are
watching issues something that's pretty
aggressive is with you please leave it
in the comments below with the folks
around for other people can be inspired
by printer cars as well and also when
you write it down much more likely to
stick for yourself enjoy
the present generation below 35 has
grown up used to high economic growth
year after year and they take security
and success for granted and because they
believe that all is well they are less
willing to make sacrifices for the
benefit of the others in society and
they are more concerned about the
individual and family's welfare and
success not the communities or the
society's well-being but this is very
dangerous because things can go terribly
wrong terribly quickly
[Music]
these people are simply not aware of
Singapore's vulnerabilities already read
about is that Singapore is either number
one or number two was the most
competitive country number one or number
two is a seaport of Airport or has
number one or number two as the airline
and from time to time they complain that
we are driving the people too hard
making life too stressful so why not
settle for number three or number four
number five does it matter
my answer is yes it does matter so if we
are not near the top in competitiveness
there is no reason why we should have a
seaport at all or an airport or an
airline when I set up my Singapore dream
that was a young man of twenty plus was
for Democratic Society keen vibrant or
United people a society based on justice
inequality it should achieve happiness
[Music]
prosperity and progress for the nation
thirty years ago
my conics younger more dreamy Island
Center the words of our pledge
[Music]
we did not focus our eyes on our labels
or we would have missed that rainbow in
the sky we pursued and that was how we
keep the bills today Singapore for the
young let me tell you the sky has turned
brighter
thus a glorious rainbow that beckons
those who the spirit of adventure
and our rich findings at the end of the
rainbow
to the young and to the not so old I say
look at the horizon
follow that rainbow go ride it
[Music]
not all of direction
Arthur fewer firing a great ability
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm quite determined I may not be able
to do it this way but when believe had
given up I'll think of some other ways
to get there I think it's necessary
because if you lack that determination
then we're not going to achieve you're
not do you will not be able to deliver I
am able to get ideas across to people in
simple ways and persuade them to my
point of view if not the first time than
the second that the fourth line I don't
give up eventually I swing them around
Tom Shelton is a great man he fought a
great revolution
he saw the product of that revolution
turned sour
he was fortunate to live long enough and
he had the courage to say no we change
cause let's learn let's stop trying to
do everything by ourselves
so they started importing and buying
Boeing 707s so their port items instead
of trying to manufacture their own atra
eventually they will but it will take
two maybe three generations that's how
we succeeded because we have open minds
common sense a lot of analysis careful
weighing of the odds make a firm
decision monetary implemented modified
as it goes wrong
and and then if it is no good life is
what you make of it your Delta part of
cars your DNA is fixed by your mother
and your father
and you may be siblings will you even
get different parts of fossils of the
DNA your job is to make the best of the
car could be handed out to you what can
you do what can you not do well order
you were sad and you asked me to make my
living as an artist Astana because I
just can't draw it wasn't it
and my father or my mother money great
grandfathers and grandmothers you asked
me to do what a magical question also
argue your point out I'll get by that's
the card I was handed out and I make you
soda don't try and do something you were
not favored by nature to do I can tell
you that when I met the SI a pilot I
didn't meet them on TV I met them face
to face
so I feet across the table so they can
see me and see whether I am still
vigorous able to campaign and take them
on brother is worth taking me on I
offered them two choices either you
argue you stopped this intimidation
which is what it was bringing as ID as I
write down disrupting services ruining
its reputation
millions of dollars worth of
advertisements and sales ruin within a
matter of two weeks
I gave them a choice continue this and I
will by every means at my disposal teach
you and get the people of Singapore let
me teach you a lesson you won't forget
and I'm prepared to start all over again
oh stop it get back to work restore
discipline then argue your case took
them sixty five minutes and they decided
okay it isn't worth the fight why
because they know they'll lose they know
that I'm prepared to ground the a line I
didn't know that I can get the a line
going again without them and let there
be no mistakes about this
whoever governs Singapore must have that
iron in him or give it up this is not a
game of card this is your life and mine
I spent a whole lifetime building this
and as long as I'm in charge nobody is
going to knock it down we have so much
at stake we have gone so far to secure
the country I see a rally around and
keep these evil forces you see we are so
shamed of themselves they have switched
the light on look at that they are kind
of that's what they are colors the
switch the light on
jerilyn are the men who are going to
lead you to peace and prosperity or to
ruination and position totally god knows
what they are doing in the dark there
are serious they succeed on the basis of
intimidation and I say if they make the
error that we are easily intimidated
then they have a lot to be sorry for
because you know we have so much at
stake we can't afford to be intimidated
what do you have so little faith in the
ability of your people
so well-educated to make intelligent
judgments on diversity of ideas when
competing news I have been in office for
now 29 years I have won seven general
elections since my first in 1959 I think
that qualifies me at least to be able to
say I do know Singapore better than the
questioner your father and grandfather's
generation lived a hard life
very few people had homes of their own
in Chinatown
you have cubicles 8 or 10 people in the
room sharing for bucks because they do
shift work save money if you lift in
those conditions and you get a a flat
one room which is what we started with
communal bathroom communal kitchen
running hot and cold water closet that's
from the lowest depths of the ship so a
deck with a window with a pothole and
everything and from that to go to a
three room or four or five roof rack you
go up to the higher levels of the ship
and finally now we've got executive
press and condominiums that means you're
on a cruise ship at the very top now I
have watched my grandchildren grow up
and they are growing up much more
comfortably and that my children and
with I want when I make them make sure
that you became self-reliant and not
somebody would pick up the balls early
as Prime Minister was given a house of
sweet mercy so I took them to I wanted
to play and see the six of the high
ground they're playing with a ball the
ball rolled down and the butler Fran bow
50 or 60 yards to pick up the ball bring
it back but water I washed Alison or if
we stay here for five years
our children will grow up believing that
life is like that
then somebody will always pick up balls
for them we stay at home and I think
that's been good for the
and that is the problem we face today
many of the parents
why is HDB flats started like the people
in Chinatown
they understand what it is to be poor
today should do not understand what it
is to be poor but you can intellectually
and emotionally understand if we don't
make the same effort you go back to
where you work we meet mistakes we put
money in you pop in Jurong secondhand
machinery you were young then we were
new in the game this older secondhand
machinery we didn't know we lost money
we wrote it off but we learned human
beings are not like computers you know
you can take one computer bank plug the
terminals and all the data for one
computer bank and go into another but
human beings start with fresh minds you
get a newborn child he grows out
completely blank input from parents
input from France input from teachers
but no input is as vivid as long-lasting
as his own experience how do I describe
my you know motivations my proclivities
if our you wanted to have a go I would
say I'm consistent
I don't see one thing today and another
tomorrow and change again day after
tomorrow
it's not that I'm inflexible the
circumstances were the situation has
altered and on to practice a world this
is no longer applies but I on the whole
life's to be consistent and if you
I had three journalists write up a book
of my speeches and I ask them at the end
that was the dominant team you found and
the three of them said consistency
throughout all the 40 years in public
life when I said at the beginning
throughout all that word that you stayed
loud and clear
I won't be this simple because you know
where you stand with me and you know
what I want to do looking back damage
independence was declared was not one
really cool celebration rejected by the
Federation of Malaysia Singapore face
the future of seemingly insurmountable
obstacles
you see the whole of my adult life I
[Applause]
believe in Malaysian larger and the
unity of these two territories you know
is people connected by geography
[Applause]
economics and ties of kinship
[Applause]
would you mind every stop for a while I
am nobody stooge
I'm not here
to please somebody else's game I have
[Music]
Human and people's lives to a council
[Music]
Singapore
we'll survive
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this movie because I need to poop
that attitude so there's a famous on
screw that is you want me to profound
back check out the link in the
description you can go and catch them
both I also let us know which clips
resonated and most of you what lesson
even occasion this video and immediately
apply to your life or to business
somehow leave it down the times the law
really curious that what you have
I also want to give a quick trailer to
Brian Tracy Brian thank you so are you
thinking of a copy of my book your one
word and posted a review on your
Facebook page I really really really
appreciate you support and so glad that
you enjoyed thank you guys so much for
watching
I even using opt to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
[Music]
what's the most important change a most
significant change in your way of
thinking about the world over the last
20 years that the impossible can happen
I never thought that the Soviet Union
will improve so easily and I never
thought the Chinese would abandon the
communist system and move into the free
market so readily it was unthinkable 20
years ago both has happened the world
has changed and it's not clear exactly
how it's all gonna play no it is not
exactly clear when it will happen
exactly but that it will happen now in
the long term 5,200 years yes and the
center of gravity is shifting to Asia
must be because the populations there
that the talent pool of 1.3 billion
people as a Japanese the Koreans and the
Vietnamese and the others so it can
match Europe and America but that talent
pool was inert did not have science and
technology did not care about science
and technology but now everything that
you do issue is doing I know calling as
a method of government I think that
shows a certain weakness of mine an
inability to chart a course whichever
way the wind blows whichever way the
media encourages the people to go you
follow you are not a leader if your
message is one of despair then you don't
you should not be a leader
you must give people hope hope of
improving that condition there are
moments of constant you feel very down
yet either because you are physically
down or emotionally down or because the
world has done adverse against me I
think when you are in that condition the
first thing you do is to get a good
night's sleep
then get a swim or chase a ball get the
cobwebs out of your mind I believe and I
practice this for all these years in
politics but if you are not fit you're
going to make mistakes physically fit
you must stay physically and mentally
fit
I exercise every day I used to go take
off golf more for relaxation just just
to get away from the smokey conference
rooms and as part of the balance you
keep now a cycle I swim even when I
travel and since the last ten years or
so I've learned to meditate because it's
one way of calming yourself it takes
practice I've had a doctor teaching he
was a Buddhist and he retired and
expenses time helping people to meditate
especially those with terminal illnesses
in order to take life calmly and I think
at the end of say 20 minutes to half an
hour bypass rate can go down from 100 to
about 60 I mean you can feel yourself
subside I mean you're still your mind
you empty your mind then when you are
rested you resume quietly you still got
the same problems
maybe you'll sleep on it come back look
at it for a few days and decide maybe
there's a better way of solving it
I'll talk to some friends get some ideas
but if you are not in good shape we are
going to make mistakes and that's
disastrous